Hi everyone and welcome to
today's Google Developers Live
for Google Drive.
Today I'm going to relive a
little bit of my former life
before I was working on Drive
and talk a little bit about
the Google Apps Marketplace.
There's a lot of developers who
have been in the Google
Apps Marketplace for the past
couple of years and who have
been integrating with Google
Docs using the
Documents List API.
And lately just been getting a
lot of questions from those
developers on how they can take
those applications and
start leveraging some of
the new features in the
Google Drive API.
And it actually turns out it's
pretty easy to get started.
There are some limitations, a
couple different options, and
how you can do it.
So I'm going to go over just
two or three different
approaches and show how they
work, what the pros and cons
of the different approaches
are, and where you start
running into limitations.
So anyway, for those who are not
familiar with the Google
Apps Marketplace, it's an
enterprise storefront really
designed for small businesses.
But it's where developers can
register their applications.
And domain administrators for
Google Apps can go and install
those applications for all of
the users on their domain.
It's been around for
a few years.
Some really great applications
in there and more still keep
coming on every day.
But when it was written, it was
actually done pre-Drive.
It was actually when Drive was
still referred to as Google
Docs and documentation and
everything is still really
geared towards the older
API, some of the older
authentication mechanisms
like OAuth1 instead of
OAuth2 and so on.
It creates a little bit of
confusion about how you can
use some of the newer APIs that
Google is doing with the
enterprise storefront.
So I want to go into our
developer console for the
marketplace here.
I already created this
app a while back.
It's called GDL Test.
And I'll just go in and
edit this listing.
Actually, you're already created
here for using the
Google Doc List API.
So I actually have the
scope reference here.
It might be a little
hard to see.
I'll make it a little
bit bigger if I can.
So you see the scope
ref doc list.
And this is just the old
Google Docs feed.
And here in my test domain, I
have this Apps Rocks domain.
And I have this app
already installed.
I have a really simple test
application here.
It's just a little bit of a
command line application using
the Ruby client.
What this has in here is just
our Client ID and Secret.
We're using two-legged OAuth1.
And I'm just going to do a
request for the Documents List
API impersonating a user using
XOAuth Requestor ID.
And then print out
the results.
And life is good.
So we see the results.
Not really worried about
formatting any of this.
It's really just to see, are
we getting back a valid
response or not?
So basically all that we just
showed is that Marketplace
apps work with the Documents
List API.
That's something that
we already knew.
So what happens when we switch
over and instead of using the
Documents List API, we
actually just go
and use Drive API?
And in this case what we
actually get back is a result.
It wasn't actually a
result I expected.
Let me go and do one
other thing.
Actually, no.
That is correct.
Basically what the point is,
is it actually just works.
And the reason this works is
really for one simple reason,
which is the Documents Lists
scope is actually respected by
the Drive API.
And it's treated as equivalent
to the full Drive scope.
There are a couple catches.
A couple things I want to point
out in how I actually
set this up here.
So one is, I want to go back
to our Google Apps
Marketplace.
Go to our vendor profile.
And there's a couple things
you can see here.
In our console for the
Marketplace, there's a link
underneath each application,
which says, register for
additional APIs.
What that will do--
let's close that other one--
is take us to a version of the
Google API console that is
tied to our Marketplace app.
And what we can do is that for
the Marketplace, we can then
go and turn on different
services such
as the Drive API.
There's one other thing though
that has to happen for this to
work reliably, which
is the API key.
Normally, the API key is
something you would only use
in the context of
unauthenticated API requests.
So if you're using some of the
APIs which aren't necessarily
tied to user data but still we
need to be tied to an API
project, you would use the API
key as a way to link any of
those API calls to
your specific
instance of the console.
And this is used for quota
enforcement, for reporting,
and various other features.
Normally, if you're using
authenticated request, this is
automatically done for you
by virtue of your OAuth
credentials.
So when you authenticate a
user, you have a token.
That token is bound to
your application.
And also, of course, bound to
your API console projects so
we can track quota.
For the Marketplace, due to
the way that the keys are
generated for your application,
that binding
isn't really there.
What you need to do in the case
of a Marketplace app-- in
addition to signing your request
with your application
client key and Secret--
you also need to set
the API key.
Most of the client libraries,
this is pretty easy.
In the case of Ruby, for
example, we just do this once
when we create the client.
So even though we're still
doing an authenticator
request, we're still signing
with our apps credential, we
still need this one additional
bit of information to make
sure that we had that correct
binding to our application.
The upshot of that is we do
actually get reporting.
You can see here's a request
we just made today.
We get quota enforcement.
It makes it a little bit
easier for us if your
application uses a lot
of API quota and you
need additional traffic.
You need additional QPS.
We can actually set those
for your project.
If you don't do that, what ends
up happening is you end
up falling into a generic bucket
of quota, which then
makes it a little bit more
unpredictable for your
application.
So that's really the easiest
way that you can actually
start using the Drive
API features.
One of the other things that
people have tried--
I'm actually going to show
you what happens.
I'm going to go and
edit this listing.
And I have another
scope in here.
I already put this in
a little earlier.
But I put in a scope
for the Drive, the
new Drive scope here.
So you see it's little bit
different the new format.
googleapis.com/auth/drive.
It's a little bit different
than the old Docs one.
And I'm going to go and change
this reference here to Drive.
And it'll save that.
I want to show you
what happens.
What ends up happening is a
little bit of UI issue.
This will actually work.
So if I go back and try
this, I'll actually
get back a 200 response.
So everything is fine.
So 200.
That's good.
But here what we lose--
instead of having that really
nice human friendly text that
says, integrates with
Google Docs, we
just get the raw scope.
And this is just mostly
a bug on our side.
There is a feature request to
update the Marketplace to have
all the latest scopes.
So while this will technically
work, it loses some of the
features in terms of
the presentation.
And it also means that-- let's
make this a little smaller--
when you do things like
searching the Marketplace,
there are some features here
for where you could filter
application based on the
type of integration.
Applications that are using the
Drive scopes are not going
to show up correctly
in this filter.
So while maybe your first
instinct is to, well I'm just
going to end up using the Drive
API, let's use the Drive
scope, you do miss out on
a lot of the Marketplace
features in terms of the
benefits for discoverability
of your application.
So really the trick to doing
this is use the old Documents
Lists scope but use the new
API so that you get the
simplicity of the API, the more
efficient wire protocols,
and of course some of the new
features that are coming out,
that we have in our early
access program that we
announced about a
week or two ago.
There's one other thing that
comes up in part of this.
Those who have been building
newer Drive applications are
probably familiar with what we
have in the Chrome Web Store,
which is these applications.
And one feature we've been
promoting is the ability for
applications to hook into the
new UI for Drive, to be in the
Create menu, to be able to open
files from the Explorer.
In fact, there was an
announcement earlier today
about how that experience has
changed to really help promote
third party applications, make
that experience of connecting
apps much better.
And as part of this, we have
two different ways that
applications can get installed
into Drive.
One is via the Chrome
Web Store.
And the other is via
an OAuth scope.
So there's a scope,
Drive.install, which does the
same thing that you would have
if you installed via the
Chrome Web Store of
having that app
appear in Google Drive.
So of course then the question
is, well can you do this from
the Apps Marketplace?
So if, for example, we were to
go into our app settings.
Here we have these different
scopes, you
have a Drives scope.
If I were to add a Drive.install
scope and then
include that into our app, the
question is, would that
actually work?
And unfortunately the answer
to that is, no it doesn't.
Due to the way that that scope
is enforced and checked, it
only works when it's actually a
grant to an individual user,
not when it's a domain-wide
grant.
There are some things you can
do as a hybrid model if you
are an application which is in
the Google Apps Marketplace
and you really love those
features of being able to do
these domain-wide might
authorizations, but you still
want get that UI integration.
Just do a hybrid model.
So you can have the domain
administrator
install your app.
That gives you data access for
all the users on the domain.
But then as they become users of
your application, just have
an upsell or some other
promotion within the
application to say-- hey, not
only can you use our app here,
but you can get all these really
cool other features
like appearing in the
Drive UI so you
can create docs directly.
Or open our application
from within Drive.
Click here to install
that extension.
Then you could either use the
OAuth, the Drive.install scope
to connect that application.
Or point them to the Chrome
Web Store instead.
So a couple different options
for how you can do that.
Honestly, it's not nearly
as polished as I
would like it to be.
There are things that we're
looking at to make this
experience a lot better.
But a lot of interest in having
those domain-wide
deployment features combined
with some of the new things
have been happening in the
Chrome Web Store are something
that we're looking at.
But it's just not
available today.
But the good news is that, if
you are in the Google Apps
Marketplace, and you have an
existing Docs integration,
there's really no reason why you
shouldn't start looking at
migrating to the
new Drive API.
You can still leverage the
two-legged OAuth and the
domain-wide grants that
you have today.
You just need to do a little
bit of work just to enable
that project, use the API key.
And then you can start using the
Drive API and any of the
new features that
are in there.
So that's really it.
It's something that, a lot of
questions from developers but
turns out to be really
simple to do.
And other than that, I think
that's all for today.
If there's any questions,
certainly feel free to ask on
the Google Drive Developers
community, Stack Overflow, or
find me on Google+.
Just send me a note.
I'll be happy to help.
Other than that, stay tuned
for next week's Google
Developers Live.
Great.
Thanks.